in today's video I talked about well a
number of things but I kind of zeroed in
on criticizing the issues with the
subscription-based life that
corporations are currently trying to
push us into having and an example
occurred to me since that video went up
that uh I really want to talk about so
I'm going to do it here so if you
weren't aware I tried to get into acting
like I was auditioning for stuff in
Boston and New York there's years and
years and years ago and as a result I
had an IMDb page with a headshot
specifically that headshot
yeah give me a break that's almost 20
years old but here's the thing
regardless of how I now present I'm
stuck with that picture now you see on
IMDb you can put up pictures for shows
or movies that's free that costs nothing
actor headshots though those cost money
and I paid up front that's why it's
there but now you have to be subscribed
to IMDb Pro to put up a new headshot and
if your subscription everlaps it
defaults back to an old one or to none